[Music]  the survival of the skies is at stake  there can be no peace the people are  desperate for justice there are some of  us who believe they can take our country  back  if we can unify and rise up behind wanna  leader  perhaps you  you are my family I cannot do this  without you how is making decisions  whatever course you are charting I  choose you my husband Robert the Bruce  to be declared an outlaw join yourself  free  is it true you are the king of scotch  go tell all your friends were going to  our country back  I have fifty men to hide the strongest  are immoral  we're dealing with outdoorsmen that  k.will hanging Patrice in  if I died tomorrow let's people die  tomorrow do whatever you must do you  understand  I wear this crown as a symbol of my duty  to serve the Scottish people  I am King of Scots  north of the land with other people  we did fight for God  what country  for fugly  you don't care so long as you buy  [Music]  you  [Music]  you